chants go Pastrana ocean debris row and
ie ultra consider a tuna as a critic we
pressed on stock well Katherine check-in
kaksi banging majority I mean at lost
son of a fled Chechnya last year she's
bisexual and she says she was beaten by
Islamic healers kept in a psychiatric
clinic against her will and drugged
there and by her own family because of
her sexual orientation yeah when you our
store and you nickel Danny Prakash at so
he devices in a tomboy he played on
Yahoo [ __ ] better us trippin you out
that pop widow from Diego these two
activists from Russia's LGBT Network
helped her escape to a country that we
can't name and they're working with her
on the case she's filed against her
parents and the individuals she says
abused her has been detected a stink
bomb Ashoka strange the calendar shall
punish me custard as a taco vodka tree
question freedafishy normal things
British pub idiot Andromeda stood no
chance of matters to us type 0 Community
[Music]
Church news capital Grozny as a
glittering modern city the mosque the
jewel at its heart the main artery named
after Vladimir Putin a catwalk for
glamorous Chechen women gender roles are
mapped out here women will marry for men
fighting and mixed martial arts is a way
of life after childhood spent during two
vicious separatist Wars we came here
just before lockdown to find out what
it's like for LGBTQ women living in a
part of Russia where women cannot even
get a passport without the consent of a
male relative
Makia ngf has spent his life defending
human rights in Chechnya he and his
staff have faced numerous threats for
the work that they do but he says he
doesn't believe there are gay women in
the Chechen Republic Fedor may be a swap
share the an academy solution he was not
registered national object at the option
it was more than a space toilet but they
do exist in Moscow last year we met a
couple who had managed to escape and
were trying to flee Russia they did not
want to show their faces and told us
that Chechen security officials were
trying to blackmail them yeah but she
slew us your words sushi sherdog
perevalne a gun in your gay transgender
long-term minions possible Sara nomina
Muslim they told us about the Islamic
medical center in Grozny the LGBT
Network say lesbians are often brought
here to try and convert them to
heterosexual life by exercising their
demons it's a center for traditional
Islamic medicine where exorcisms are
standard this doctor had agreed to show
us around we had hoped we could ask him
about women brought here for conversion
therapy because of their sexuality but
then he receives a phone call and we're
told to leave
the director is close to Chechen leader
Ramzan Kadyrov and he hasn't had
approval from the top did you must June
the me it does the this add-on Chechen
TV shows an exorcism in process a way to
restore harmony the advert suggests if
you're having problems with your wife
those Oliver says that what happened to
her was brutal on his borromeo both
social split Aeneas Johnson and gusto is
Gwinnett is managing on Union College
pt2 Natasha it evolved on me it could
show me Oaxaca Ron the church and
Investigative Committee has assigned a
number to loss on of his case but there
is a culture of impunity here the Kadir
of regiment for example behind these
walls is notorious for torture and
unlawful detentions so here on the left
you have the headquarters of the Khedira
of regiment and on the right there in
that yellow building is the headquarters
of the local Investigative Committee
which goes some way to explaining why
there has been such a failure to
investigate or prosecute allegations of
torture by law enforcement officials in
Chechnya and bloody what you see
missionaries no mediator these three
aren't confident and the case will go
anywhere but by speaking out they hope
loss on of our shows others that they're
not alone that however difficult it is
there can be a way out
no but you're a poor teacher but as Iran
you Diana Magnay Sky News Grozny
Chechnya shortcut hero